this bat vigilante is like a one-man
rite of terror
the press has to do the right thing you
don't get to decide what the right thing
is nobody cares about Clark Kent taking
on the Batman
next time they shine your light in the
sky don't go to it the bat is dead bury
it you're gonna go to wall he's the one
that brought the war to us count the
dead thousands of people what's next
millions
he has the power to wipe out the entire
human race and if we believe there's
even a one-percent chance that he is our
enemy we have to take it as an absolute
certainty we have to destroy you hey
guys zac snyder director of Batman V
Superman dawn of justice and looked at
time has come to pick a side hashtag
Batman hashtag Superman use the emojis
to decide who will win tell me do you
play
hey youtubers is charlie so new Batman V
Superman footage dropped during the
football game it's a little bit
different from the previous trailer
mostly focusing on Superman's character
there's also the zacks matter call out
which i think is a little funny because
it's very obvious marketing like they're
just playing up this big battle between
the dark knight and the Man of Steel but
it is entertaining it's just funny when
you know that this isn't necessarily
going to be the narrative of the film
it's kind of like the deal with Finn
holding the lightsabers and all the Star
Wars trailers they wanted you to think
that he was going to be a Jedi when
really the narrative of the movie was
completely different but really this
trailer is the same trailer as the last
one it's just told from Superman's
perspective there are a few different
scenes that just kind of shift the
perspective to Superman being this
sanctimonious [ __ ] as Batman would
probably call him looking at Batman's
doing and thinking of him as a criminal
that needs to be stopped the bat is dead
bury him the next time your signal
lights up don't go to it this party
scene seems like it happens pretty early
in the film I'm wondering if it happens
before their first encounter in the
costumes like they meet each other is
Bruce Wayne and Clark Kent and then they
also meet each other is Batman and
Superman for the first time I'm
wondering which comes first it seems
like this party will happen first it'll
be relatively early in the film but as
the film picks up Batman gets this call
to action we see like the training
montage him start branding criminals
then Clark Kent responds then we have
this party then they start meeting as
Batman and Superman in the costumes and
we get to this moment where Superman
passes judgment I could kill you if I
wanted to I don't want to I'm just
telling you to stop being Batman or else
dot dot and that you know then a
Batman's obviously like do you bleed
because you will so something's telling
me that this is all happening in the
first two acts of the film because Zack
Snyder like all the big doomsday stuff
Zack Snyder's like that's not even the
biggest stuff in the film that's
probably my third act leaving the final
act of the film for something even
crazier I'm guessing based on some of
the toys it might involve a version of
the leg suit from the comics the the
mech suit that Lex where's the thing
about that and some information that
Zack Snyder has talked about that I
don't think has been in any of the
trailers is is that Lex Luthor has
always been envious of Bruce Wayne just
because of his company all the things
his family is done that's why he's
trying to hype LexCorp
this huge corporation there's actually
been some viral marketing that shows
like this chart here like the relative
capitalization of all these companies
Bruce Wayne's company's fallen onto hard
times is Lex corpus burgeoned into this
giant tech conglomerate so already
you're seeing Lex's Napoleon complex and
technically the Lex of this movie is
Alexander Luthor jr. so you just
remember that even though Lex Luthor
typically thought of as the biggest
Superman villain of all time also a big
Batman villain in this film but I don't
think that we know whether or not Lex
knows Bruce Wayne is Batman he might not
know that but he is aware of Batman
clearly because he's pitting him against
Superman let me know in the comments
though just based on the marketing of
the film so far which perspective do you
drift more towards like are you leaning
more in supermans direction batman is
kind of this crazy vigilante going way
over the line you need to stop him were
you leaning more in Batman's direction
and Superman does this crazy godlike
figure is gonna do more harm than good
especially if we can't control them and
we don't know what his true intentions
are that's kind of where this Senate
hearing stuff comes in I think that's
really where Wonder Woman comes in to be
the bridge between Batman and Superman
as well as the bridge between Superman
in the government I know he's on the
teaser trailer for the Wonder Woman
movie that takes place during World War
one obviously she's probably going to be
doing the same thing in that movie where
she tries to be a bridge between the
Amazonians the real world as well as a
bridge between all the superpowers in
the quest for peace which actually makes
me think of Superman for the quest for
peace that's a really good film to watch
if you're looking for cheese ball
Christopher Reeve if you really like the
cheese ball Superman films and they
really did go cheese ball with Superman
three and four a new giveaway winner
congratulations to gatech Troy just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel you in a reverse flash
ring the giveaway is continuing all you
have to do to enter it is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll announce the next winter when
I post my flash video next Tuesday just
in case you guys haven't seen it i
posted a big Suicide Squad trailer video
talking about Nightwing the tattooed man
who they are why they might be in the
movie
you can click here to watch that and you
can click here to watch the warcraft
trailer that i just posted thank you so
much for watching everybody looks like
fun i'll see you guys tonight
you